my name is Charles Balin I'm a professor
of astronomy and physics here at Yale
I'm also the director of undergraduate
studies in astronomy and today it's my
great pleasure to introduce the third of
this year's Terry lectures now I have to
confess that those of us who teach
astronomy have a kind of ongoing
low-level embarrassment and this is the
fact that what we want to teach our
students is not the same thing as what
our students want to learn from us and
in the topic of cosmology for example
we're very comfortable talking about the
two and three-point correlation function
of galaxies about the power spectrum of
perturbations in the Cosmic Microwave
Background I mean about the possibility
of observing baryon acoustic
oscillations in large scale surveys of
the sky but for some reason our students
don't ask us those questions rather they
ask us questions of the type what
happened before the Big Bang where is
the edge of the universe and what lies
beyond it and to these kinds of
questions we kind of smiled nervously
and try and retrack the conversation
back to something we're more comfortable
with so there is this kind of gap
between what we think we know and what
our students and our colleagues in other
fields and the public wishes we knew
into this gap have boldly gone Joel are
Premack and Nancy Ellen Abrams our
speakers for this set of Terry lectures
Joel Premack is a distinguished
astrophysicist who has made major
contributions to the understanding of
dark matter and how dark matter
influences cosmic structure Nancy Allan
Abrams can only be described as a
polymath she's a philosopher she's an
attorney with a specialty in conflict
resolution she's a musician and many
other things and together they have gone
where the rest of us dare not and have
attempted to address the really big
questions and today is the third of
their four
lectures and they'll be talking about as
I understand it they'll be talking about
this cosmically pivotal moment which I
assume turns out to be now thank you
very much and Nancy and Joey look
forward to Thank You Charles it's always
hard to be the third person to introduce
the same people so that was really very
creative well welcome to the third
lecture this cosmically pivotal moment a
moment is cosmically pivotal when the
direction of the very long-term future
hinges on what happens in that moment
and how likely is it that today really
is a pivotal moment the probability
seems almost zero that in a 14 billion
year old universe anything should be
special about the vanishingly small
window of 21st century earth so perhaps
claiming that today is cosmically
pivotal seems grandiose nonsense but let
me suggest don't look at the probability
look at the evidence the first thing
we're going to do in this lecture is to
outline how we are in fact living at a
pivotal moment not only from the point
of view of humanity but of the earth the
solar system and the universe then we'll
explore what the pivotal nature of this
moment may mean and why it matters for
all major political decisions being made
today intentionally changing the course
of post-industrial civilization has
never been done before but we believe
that a cosmic society could do it Joel
and I are not arguing to use cosmology
directly to reach better policy
decisions what we're advocating is to
use cosmology to develop an encompassing
understanding of our planet a new
awareness of the cosmic context
surrounding and to some extent
controlling global human affairs and the
human earth relationship now in lecture
1 we showed that the way people look at
their cosmos is reflected in the way
that they see their own culture and if
their cosmos is narrower
and largely fictitious their perspective
on everything is narrow and largely
fictitious this is part of our problem
today we showed in lecture 1 that
there's actually a largest and a
smallest possible size permitted by the
laws of physics and they may be linked
we symbolize this with the cosmocorps Oh
Boris a serpent swallowing its tail and
in this finite but vast range of sizes
it turns out that we human beings we
intelligent beings are central and we
couldn't be anywhere else our nature
arises from the nature of the universe
in lecture 2 we showed that although we
and everything we see including the
entire earth are made of atoms all the
atoms except hydrogen and helium are
actually very rare and even hydrogen and
helium make up only a small fraction of
the cosmic density most of the universe
is made of dark matter and dark energy
whose dynamic interactions since the
beginning of the universe have shaped
the galaxies which are the only possible
homes where life could have evolved so
we are made of the rarest material in
the universe but our existence is
supported by a massive pyramid of
invisible matter and energy in lecture
tube we also explained that like all
observers we are at the center of our
cosmic horizon we're surrounded by
cosmic spheres of time since as we look
out into space we're looking back in
time and we're receiving radiation from
all of these previous cosmic epochs now
in this lecture we will focus on the
pivotal nature of this moment in time
because it turns out that by
understanding the newly discovered
larger universe we acquire new concepts
that could give us the perspective we
need to understand how our technologies
are already having effects on the
planetary and cosmic time scales but
without these new cosmological concepts
it will be very difficult to get a
mental grasp on what we humans have to
do to
preserve ourselves and all of our
potential first we have to start
thinking cosmically about time that is
time on the scale of the cosmos the
ability to think this way is new to our
species politicians certainly aren't
using it yet and in our daily lives it
hasn't seemed necessary to think much
further into the future the next year or
when the kids go to college or the
family legacy but this has to change and
it can let's look briefly at how
people's ideas of time have changed in
the past for millennia it was assumed in
the West as Genesis implies that human
beings like us have been on the earth
for its entire existence except for the
first five days then in the 19th century
the science of geology took off and
scientists tried to understand how
mountains and river deltas formed they
were shocked to discover that some
formations must have taken hundreds of
millions of years this was the beginning
of the discovery of deep time throughout
the 19th century as excavation for
railroads occurred across England of the
United States dinosaur bones and other
fossils were uncovered and the
realization dawned on people that
countless entire species had gone
extinct long ago by the mid 20th century
scientists using radioactivity
determined that the earth and the solar
system itself are far older still 4.6
billion years old compared to this vast
age we humans just evolved this morning
and we have appeared at a very
particular moment the midpoint of time
what does it mean to call this the
midpoint of time well as I'll explain we
live at the peak moment in the history
of the universe for astronomical
observation this is also the middle of
the existence of our solar system it's
the midpoint of time for the evolution
of complex life on earth and it's the
end of the
financial expansion of the human impact
on earth let's start with the first one
now is the peak moment in the lifetime
of the universe for astronomical
observation there will never again be so
many galaxies visible as there are in
this ultra deep field from the Hubble
Space Telescope how is this possible
well all distant galaxies are moving
away from our Milky Way and the farther
away a galaxy is located the faster it's
moving away because the expansion of the
universe is now accelerating the most
distant galaxies are beginning to
disappear over the cosmic horizon
meanwhile in about 5 billion years our
own Milky Way will merge with the great
galaxy and Andromeda and many of the
satellite galaxies will also merge and
this will form one big galaxy that we
might call Milky Andromeda let's look at
what that might look like so I'm going
to show you a video that my team made it
represents a merger between galaxies
like the Milky Way and the Andromeda
galaxy these are realistic color images
galaxy mergers like this one trigger
gigantic starbursts forming many
millions of new stars which look blue in
the resulting images but dust which
appears orange or brown in these images
absorbs up to ninety percent of the
light especially when new stars are
being formed and this energy is radiated
in invisible long wavelengths what we're
going to show is just what these
galaxies would look like to Hubble Space
Telescope
so there's one galaxy say ours and now
we'll set it going toward this other
galaxies say Andromeda as the galaxies
pass each other their gravitational
interaction triggers a gigantic
starburst look at all those newly formed
stars in blue
gravity's pulling them back together
their centers merge
and now the Stars that surrounded these
galaxies in the disk form a giant ball
of stars an elliptical galaxy the whole
process takes about two billion years
it's now finished and we're moving the
camera around the elliptical galaxy
there's a big dust Lane about to a cross
that our field of view and we see these
in elliptical galaxies that we see in
telescopes incidentally when galaxies
merged almost no stars collide because
stars are so tiny compared to the
immense spaces between them far in the
future milky Andromeda will be all
that's visible to anyone living inside
it and it will be impossible for
evermore to see any other galaxies it
took billions of years of cosmic
evolution to build up the Stardust
required for earth-like planets and then
billions of years of biological
evolution on earth for creatures to
evolve with the technological capability
to see the distant galaxies so such
observations couldn't have happened much
sooner than now thus this is the peak
moment in the history of the universe
for astronomical observation as I said
before they will never again be so many
galaxies visible so we astronomers are
telling the funding agencies fund us
quick closer to home we're living in the
middle of the existence of our solar
system in about six billion years the
evolving Sun will puff up into a red
giant star that will swallow the inner
planets of mercury and venus and
possibly burn earth to a crisp since as
I mentioned the solar system is now
about four and a half billion years old
this means that we're close to the
middle of the roughly ten billion year
lifetime of a star like our Sun third on
earth we're living at the midpoint of
time for the evolution of complex life
this is the middle of the approximately
1 billion year
lush and habitable period of Earth's
existence when it has an oxygen-rich
atmosphere and lots of water the age of
animals began about half a billion years
ago with the so-called Cambrian
explosion when microorganisms increase
the oxygen content of the atmosphere to
nearly its present level and the large
animal started to evolve another half
billion years or so the increasing heat
output of the Sun will evaporate the
oceans and the sun's ultraviolet light
will dissociate water vapor at the top
of the atmosphere and most of the
hydrogen will be permanently lost earth
would then become a dune planet some of
you may remember the science fiction
novel but don't worry the Sun will
provider with a perfectly liveable
amount of heat and light for at least
several hundred million years an almost
unimaginably long time plus as the Sun
heats up our descendants will have
plenty of time the billions of
generations to move to another suitable
planetary system or movers farther from
the Sun a way this could be done is by
changing the orbits of large comets to
borrow energy from Jupiter and transfer
it to earth every hundred thousand years
or so our distant descendants would need
to do this no rush carefully of course
the fourth way that we're living at the
midpoint of time is that this is a
pivotal moment for Humanity our
collective behavior is mirroring the
greatest pivot point in the history of
the universe the beginning first let me
explain what may have happened in this
earliest instant of the Big Bang and
then we'll get to the way humanity today
is mirroring that instant there is
substantial scientific evidence that a
brief period called cosmic inflation may
be what set up the initial conditions
for the Big Bang cosmic inflation caused
the universe to expand exponentially
doubling in size again and again
incredibly fast this makes the universe
have a very Euclidian or flat geometry
as observed
in that fraction of a second of cosmic
inflation the universe expanded from
close to the Planck length all the way
up to the human scale that's just as
much in powers of 10 as it has in the
13.7 billion years since then that's how
fast exponential growth can be that
first part took almost no time quantum
effects that were happening during that
brief moment of cosmic inflation were
then expanded exponentially then the
exponential growth stopped and those
quantum effects froze into space time
and a unique pattern of wrinkles like
the lines on your hand cosmic inflation
creates exactly the sort of fluctuations
that is small differences the amount of
stuff from space this from place to
place that could grow with cold dark
matter into the galaxy distribution that
we saw in the videos in lectures 1 and 2
the great chains clusters and
superclusters of galaxies along the
filaments in the cosmic web this
expanding cosmic web was the blueprint
for our universe it was created during
the brief inflationary period and the
entire universe since then has been
built on it thus the effects of the
brief period of cosmic inflation can
reverberate forever this reverberation
is in some sense our universe all the
interesting parts of the story the
growth of galaxies of stars of heavy
elements of planetary systems life and
intelligence happened after the brief
exponential expansion of cosmic
inflation how reliable is the theory of
cosmic inflation it makes six key
predictions and thus far it's been
possible to test five of them and
they've all been found to agree with
observations cosmic inflation is
furthermore the only theory known that
sets up the proper initial conditions
for the Big Bang in addition it appears
compatible with our modern theories of
particle physics it's definitely a
theory to be taken through
really now here is how our collective
behavior is mirroring the beginning of
the universe humanity's recently been
going through its own version of
inflation growing exponentially in
population and our impacts on the earth
exponential growth occurs whenever the
rate of growth of something is
proportional to the thing itself
compound interest works like that a
certain time T is required for the
amount to double after twice that time
it doubles again another time T double
again let me illustrate this with
hypothetical pond scum that can double
each day so the first day a little bit
of pond scum day two twice as much day
three another doubling day four doubles
again day five starting to get serious
day six half the pond is covered day
seven hope you can appreciate that it's
really been speeding up there it's shown
graphically now in any finite
environment environment exponential
growth like this has to stop this is the
history of the human population for the
last 2,000 years and it's been growing
very rapidly more or less exponentially
for the last 200 years in 1800 there
were about a billion people on earth in
the past two centuries the population is
increased by a factor of six there were
two doublings a factor four in the last
hundred years alone that can never
happen again in fact population experts
agree that the earth cannot support even
one more doubling of the human
population in biology exponential growth
occurs when a species gets into runaway
reproduction it over concerns the
resources of its environmental niche and
then there's an abrupt die off
thankfully we humans now know enough to
be able to foresee
such dangers are we smarter than pond
scum there's been even faster
exponential growth in our use of natural
resources so although the populations
increased by a factor six in the last
200 years the economic output has
increased by a factor of a hundred our
energy used by a factor of 30 our carbon
dioxide production by a factor of 20 our
mobility in kilometers per person per
day worldwide by a factor of a thousand
the US and a few other countries are
producing far more than our share of
carbon dioxide so this graph this
picture shows that the United States and
China are the only two countries that
are producing a huge amount over five
thousand five million thousands so five
trillion tons of carbon dioxide per year
this shows the same graph the same map
but now we're showing the per capita
production and there's no country that
rivals the United States and per capita
production of carbon dioxide but it's
not just carbon dioxide that's the
problem as this figure shows a typical
person in United States uses his or her
weight in materials fuel and food every
day for everyone in the world to reach
present us levels of consumption as
billions aspire to do would with present
technology require for more planet
Earth's increases in greenhouse gases
are now causing worldwide climate
changes the effects of which we're
already seeing in the form of
record-breaking heat waves melting of
the polar ice caps we're running out of
fresh water and topsoil worldwide we've
destroyed more than half of the Earth's
forests and wetlands and we're
approaching repro creating for human
consumption a large and increasing
fraction of the biological productivity
of the entire Earth our options are
not just individual organisms but wiping
out entire species at the greatest rate
since the extinction of the dinosaurs
and many other species from a meteor
impact 65 million years ago clearly we
are already beginning to hit material
limits we need to figure out quickly how
to transition out of this current period
of worldwide inflationary growth in our
impact on the planet but to do so as
gently and justly as possible there is a
strong parallel between the brief
transition from cosmic inflation to
steady expansion of the universe and the
brief transition on planet Earth from
human inflationary growth to
sustainability we're living through that
transition right now but by the time
this kind of problem becomes obvious
enough that everyone recognizing
recognizes it and the detractors
actually shut up it's too late and
sometimes a cartoon will say it all 1990
global warming doesn't exist 1995 okay
it exists but it isn't man-made 2000 ok
so it's man-made but its effects aren't
all bad 2005 its effects will be really
bad but not until after I'm dead and
it's not a funny cartoon and we could
even add 2010 how can I make money off
the melting of the polar ice caps a
little more detail on the production of
carbon in the atmosphere so this is a
plot of all the different human sources
of carbon emission and the basic point I
want you to appreciate is that a
increase in a factor of a hundred and
industrial output in 200 years
corresponds to doubling every 30 years
so I've over plotted in orange what it
would look like to double every 30 years
and you see that certainly for the last
hundred years that's a pretty good
representation of our increasing carbon
and carbon dioxide production now
you'll notice that all of the greenhouse
gases carbon dioxide in red methane in
blue nitrous oxide and black for example
have shown just in the last few years
this sudden jump notice is suppressed
zero now what you have to understand is
that all this is is the effect of that
doubling every 30 years going down here
the human production was negligible
before compared to the oscillations in
the natural production but then about 20
years ago the human production became
comparable to the natural production and
then with our rapid increase it's going
up very very fast the amount of carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere can be tracked
precisely by simply looking at the
contents of little bubbles of air in ice
cores and this is the record going back
eight hundred thousand years this graph
is from a recent report that the US
government just put out a couple of
months ago you also can see that the
carbon dioxide increase in the last 20
years has tracked rather well the
overall increase in temperature which
has gone up by about one degree
Fahrenheit in the last 50 years now the
question is where is he going to go the
carbon dioxide it's about 390 parts per
million today remember it's never been
above 300 parts per million for a long
time it's going to be somewhere between
about five hundred and nine hundred or a
thousand parts per million in about a
hundred years the consequences for
climate are going to be pretty severe
that I'm going to explain in a few
minutes in his election night victory
speech then president-elect Obama told
the story of a hundred and six year old
voter named and Nixon Cooper whom he had
met and he described the momentous
changes that have happened in the United
States during her lifetime let's watch
that
we had come so far we have seen so much
but there's so much more to do so
tonight let us ask ourselves if our
children should live to see the next
section if my daughters should be so
lucky to live as long as admix and
Cooper what change will they see what
progress will we have made this is our
chance to answer that call this is our
moment this is our time President Obama
here has challenged the nation to think
a hundred years ahead to a time when his
daughters Malia and Sasha might be as
old as an Nixon Cooper but let's call
that time of the year 21 08 the Malia
Sasha horizon if our political leaders
business leaders cultural leaders and
voters simply began today to consider as
real the impact of their own decisions
just out to the Malia Sasha horizon this
would be a giant first step in expanding
our practical consciousness to
cosmological time the first step is the
most important because it sets the
direction and it overcomes inertia in
1976 I was a young lawyer in the
congressional office of Technology
Assessment which provided independent
science advice to Congress it was
abolished after the Republican
revolution in 1994 my office already saw
evidence in the 1970s that the earth was
warming that cheap oil was running out
that our health care system was
unsustainable the job of my own section
was to think about the long-term but the
long as anyone ever thought about was 30
years in Washington where major
decisions can be made with an eye to the
current crisis or the next election most
people considered 30 years in absurdly
luxurious and highly unrealistic time
scale and they didn't take it seriously
the result is that now those 30 years
have passed and every one of those
problems has only gotten worse now we
are running
out of time we can't continue this
exponential growth rate a resource
depletion and degradation of the
atmosphere but unfortunately knowing
this is not enough now let me link this
to the Malia Sasha horizon here's some
more graphs from that report i mentioned
in the 2007 Intergovernmental Panel on
Climate Change report they considered a
number of different scenarios and I want
to focus here on two of them let's call
them a and B the B scenario is one of
the most optimistic they considered
where the amount of carbon that's used
peaks in about 20 40 and 30 years and
then steadily declines the a2 scenario
is more or less business as usual in the
a1 even more so and the amount of carbon
keeps going up to the end of the century
the Malia Sasha horizon the consequence
is that in b1 the atmospheric level of
carbon carbon dioxide levels out at
about five hundred fifty parts per
million whereas in the a scenarios it's
around nine hundred parts per million by
the Malia Sasha horizon the consequence
based on a whole suite of climate models
is that compared to the one degree since
nineteen fifty of average increase in
global temperature there's a 4 degree
increase that's four times as much by
the Malia Sasha horizon with the
optimistic scenario and about seven or
eight times as much in these a scenarios
how we doing now well let's just look at
the beginning of this projection that's
blown up here and what you see is that
the actual amount of carbon that we're
putting into the atmosphere has been
growing even faster than the pessimistic
projections now what are the
consequences for the United
dates temperatures this is the
optimistic scenario the B scenario and
well just to focus on Connecticut here
what you see is about a two degree
temperature rise and forty years so
double the increase since 1950 and by
the end of the century about a four
degree temperature rise in other words
four times the amount in the last 50
years but now let's look at the
pessimistic scenario the a scenario in
40 years there's a factor of four
increase locally and by the end of the
century all across the country even in
Connecticut it's about eight degrees
eight times the temperature rise since
1950 the consequences for climate are
pretty drastic there's no question that
we have to stop binging on carbon-based
energy sources but there are lots of
questions about how best to do that one
of the big questions is the role of
nuclear power in the 1970s and 1980s the
dangers of nuclear power combined with
its huge expense convinced many of us
that nuclear was not a long-term
solution even today our country has not
figured out how to dispose of nuclear
waste in a way that will be safe for the
tens of thousands of years that it will
remain radioactive these are major
negatives for nuclear power but on the
other hand we have a potentially much
bigger crisis on our hands if humanity
keeps pouring carbon into the atmosphere
the climate destabilizes ocean currents
change and around the world there are
extreme droughts starvation wildfires
floods disease is spreading where they
were never seen before and countless
climate refugees roaming the globe and
fighting just for a place to live so on
second thought if nuclear-power could
seriously help avoid
is fate we have to reconsider it with an
open mind and ask could it be made safe
and economically competitive how so and
which version would be best but whom can
we trust to answer these questions not
the utilities whose goal is their bottom
line but the relevant government
agencies besieged by lobbyists and the
media and juggling economic political
and social pressures rarely have the
ability to figure out what are the
scientifically most responsible answers
I invented a method to deal with this
kind of situation when I was working at
the office of Technology Assessment it's
called scientific mediation it's never
been attempted in the United States to
my knowledge but it was very successful
when the Swedish government used it to
help determine if their utilities plan
for nuclear waste disposal was adequate
the result was so illuminating that
scientific mediation became standard
procedure in the Swedish Ministry of
Industry so let me briefly explain it to
do a scientific mediation a government
agency basically only needs three people
one well respected expert scientist on
each side and a mediator I played the
role of the mediator in Sweden each
scientist believes that the existing
data favors his or her position with the
help of the mediator the opposing
scientists must must collaborate on a
joint report in which they do three
things first they have to list the main
points of disagreement second they have
to state the arguments not only for
their own side but for the other side
until they satisfy their opponent that
they understand his or her position and
third which is the most illuminating
part they have to agree on why they
disagree point for point they never
agree on scientific questions that they
disagree on but they agree on why they
disagree then both of them signed the
final document scientists and other
expert advisors to government or human
beings like everybody else they can mix
personal bias
into their official positions sometimes
without even realizing that they're
doing it but during this unusual
procedure of scientific mediation those
biases surface and it becomes clear
which of their policy recommendations if
any are truly based on science when
their report is made public anyone can
understand the dispute and what is at
stake far better in fact then the
scientists themselves did at the
beginning if some government agency or
foundation sponsored a real scientific
mediation on the question of whether
nuclear power could be made safe or any
fundamental scientific question
underline lying a current policy dispute
we the people would come out of it with
the best understanding possible at this
time and one that would be fair to all
sides that alone would be invaluable
what the country decides to do about it
well let's battle it out that's what
politics is for and a cosmic society
will still be a political society but
let's first demand that all options
being fought over are grounded in
reality we're looking for a shareable
picture of reality that's based on
science and from which we can proceed to
plan our future thank you cosmology is
not necessary to diagnose our global
predicament many people see it but
cosmology could help us see the way out
the universe's inflationary period ended
with a big bang but this was good only
after inflation the universe enter its
most creative and long-lived phase
evolution takes time the fundamental
character of the universe has been to
grow in complexity and this could be our
future to that pivotal moment when the
universe transitioned from exponentially
explosive growth to slow expansion could
become a model for how to think about
the transition to sustainability that we
humans are about to make let me be more
precise like the quantum fluctuations
that froze into wrinkles in space-time
when inflation suddenly stopped
political and social decisions made
during these final years of human
inflationary growth may end up getting
frozen into the future of our species
and our planet nothing could be less
useful than to think that politics
doesn't matter today's actions and
failures to act may reverberate into the
distant future far out of proportion to
the thought that's going into them on
the plus side there are many fine people
genuinely trying to save the earth but
they often assume that the only solution
is that growth of population and
resource use must stop and then decrease
but if we take the universe as our model
we notice that at the end of cosmic
inflation the universe did not in fact
stop dead like a truck hitting a brick
wall the exponential rate of growth
stopped but not growth itself universe
essentially slammed on the brakes slowed
to a crawl and kept going for the next
14 billion years inflationary growth
that is transformed to slow but steady
expansion can go on for billions of
years for us this means that the end of
exponential growth which is approaching
is like the end of adolescence it's a
coming of age and from then on the
growth of complexity and human
civilization will be physical anymore
but intellectual emotional artistic
relational and spiritual in this age of
electronics and information it should be
possible for Humanity to achieve
sustainable prosperity without
profligate resource use fact only
without it if we take the universe as
our model we should plan for and seek a
stable period and resource use which can
only happen with renewables the universe
of course may this shift naturally for
it injustice suffering addiction
fatalism did not have to be overcome
because they didn't exist but for us
they do nevertheless we have the
knowledge and the internal resources to
overcome them only resource heavy
activities have to slow down our drive
for meaning speed
virtual connection personal expression
and cultural growth can be unlimited if
those were valued above consumer goods
which they tend to be only after people
lose them then we would have a new
paradigm for human progress for our
universe the most creative period came
after inflation ended and this could
also be true for Humanity a stable
period can last as long as our
creativity stays ahead of our physical
impact on the earth the key to
sustainability is to find the ideal
growth rate that allows human ingenuity
to stay just ahead of resource use by
foreseeing and minimizing consequences
people sometimes assume that to maintain
a stable environment innovation must be
suppressed but the opposite is the truth
non-stop creativity will be essential to
maintain long-term stability those of us
who are alive today and especially you
who are young will determine whether
this happens or not either way is a huge
choice that will determine the character
for better or worse of the long-term
future this is what it means to be
living at a cosmically pivotal moment I
want to give you an example that pulls
together in a rather practical way the
idea that we're living at a pivotal
moment with the idea from lecture 1 the
different ways of thinking are required
on different sized skills and time
skills in this example you'll see a
stark mismatch between today's very
short-term economic and political
thinking and potential long-term
consequences for the entire planet and
future generations destruction of the
space environment by space debris is the
problem and Nancy and I have been
working for years to try to solve it in
1988 Nancy and I traveled to the old
Soviet Union and a collaborative effort
of American and Soviet scientists and
international lawyers we were trying to
end the practice of launching nuclear
reactors into orbit to power satellites
I want to emphasize that i'm talking
about nuclear reactors with a minimum of
50
grams of high enriched uranium plutonium
power packs those reactors would
eventually become radioactive space
debris the USSR had already launched
about 40 of them and two had fallen back
to earth one of them contaminating a
200-mile swath of northern Canada with
radiation this shows the orbits of the
radioactive of the the nuclear reactor
powered satellites and this was part of
the clean-up operation after one of them
fell back to earth in 1978 over northern
Canada this is from a scientific
American article of my colleagues and I
Russian and American published back in
1991 the US meanwhile was planning to
launch much bigger nuclear reactors to
power missile defense popularly known as
Star Wars and we thought the USSR might
be willing to stop their reactor
launching program if the US would not
start now actually I should explain the
u.s. launched the first of these nuclear
reactor powered satellites we actually
got the Soviet government to agree not
to launch any new reactors for two years
but by the end of two years the Soviet
Union it ceased to exist and no more
nuclear reactors have ever been launched
into space many people heard about the
space debris issue for the first time on
februari tenth of this year when an
American communication satellite and the
defunct Russian satellite moving in
different orbits at about 17,000 miles
per hour crashed into each other and
broke up into countless pieces when that
kind of thing happens it's not like the
science fiction movies where there are
big explosions and then space clears in
this scene from the first Star Wars
movie on the left you see a big
explosion in space near a planet and
then a moment later the pieces disappear
in the view from the cockpit is
perfectly clear what really happens in
the collision in space is that some
pieces fall toward Earth and burn up in
the atmosphere but the rest go into
erratic orbits they move at speeds 10
times faster than a high-powered rifle
bullet is the number of satellites and
pieces of
lights a given altitude increases
eventually a chain reaction begins with
enough orbiting debris pieces begin to
hit other pieces smashing them into
fragments which will in turn hit more
pieces the process may already have
begun over 10,000 pieces larger than 10
centimeters in size are now tracked but
countless smaller ones are not tracked
no one knows exactly where they are this
is a blow-up of the region right near
the earth and this happens to be the
situation at one particular moment on
May seventh of this year I got this from
NASA this issue matters because space is
our most fragile environment that has
the least ability to repair itself only
the Earth's atmosphere can remove
satellites from orbit when the Sun
flares up in its 11-year cycle it heats
the upper atmosphere and makes it expand
so that debris and spacecraft and low
orbits are subjected to increase drag
and start to come down but the higher
the original orbit the less air and high
enough debris there's nothing to stop
them and bring them down terrible as
they are millions of land mines leftover
from earlier wars in Afghanistan and
other countries can eventually be
removed but debris in orbit higher than
800 kilometres above the Earth's surface
will be up there for decades above a
thousand kilometer for centuries above
1500 kilometers effectively forever
there's no known way to clean up space
debris any bucket put up there to catch
the pieces with itself just become
debris when you realize how long a
civilization humanity could have and how
much we have to do now to protect that
future you realize the importance of
this issue we're not going to want to
give up satellites if our future
development is going to be based on
improved cultural links rather than
endless resource consumption we have to
protect our means of communication we'll
need satellites for a very long time but
we can't keep launching new ones
indefinitely without bringing down the
old ones what are we thinking once we
realize that we are at the midpoint of
time it becomes common sense a new
common sense
to insist that every satellite launched
by anyone in the world have a rocket on
it that allows it to be brought down
safely this can be done humanity only
gets one chance to save space for all
future generations and now is it but
accidental collisions is based abri or
not the worst threat to the space
environment the worst threat is war in
space the public debate over Star Wars
has gone on and on in the United States
for a quarter of a century since the
Reagan years and it's focused on the
massive cost and unlikelihood that the
system could work but the debate has
mostly missed the most crucial point
even one war in space will create a
battlefield that will last effectively
forever encasing our entire planet
inside a shell of speeding metal shards
this will make space near Earth highly
hazardous for peaceful as well as
military purposes no actual war in space
even has to be fought to create this
catastrophe preparation for it is enough
because any country that felt threatened
by some other countries lasers or other
weapons in space could wants the
equivalent of gravel to destroy the
sophisticated weaponry and also destroy
any civilian satellites at that altitude
like those we all depend on for weather
information global positioning or
communications so here's a list of
suggested space protection principles
don't introduce attack weapons into
space avoid fragmentation of satellites
prohibit explosions of any kind in space
require all satellites to re-enter when
their useful life is over BAM nuclear
reactors in orbit minimize light
pollution from orbit political alliances
are always shifting sometimes
drastically our deadliest enemies 65
years ago the Germans and the Japanese
have been among our closest allies for
decades already it may seem that jazzy
new weapons in space will give us a leg
up over the arch enemy of the day
whoever that may be but in making this
choice we actually become our own arch
enemy any temporary military advantage
would pale before the overwhelming
eternal immorality of imprisoning earth
for thousands of years in a
ello of bullets most evil possible twist
on the idea of a halo no one can predict
what the country will be like when Malia
and Sasha are old but we have a moral
obligation to take into account the
likely impacts of our own current
decisions at least out to the Malia
Sasha horizon and we have an
intellectual obligation to base those
projections on solid science which will
require new approaches like scientific
mediation to get that level of science
into the policy-making process how
should we think about the long-term some
Native Americans have the concept of
responsibility to the seventh generation
a wonderful impulse that actually I
believe some paper towels have been
named after but the phrase is wrong for
our time because it makes it sound as
though every generation has the same
responsibility but we who are alive
today have a far larger responsibility
than earlier less knowledgeable
generations or later less pivotal
generations no one actually chose us for
this responsibility we just happen to be
the ones living at what must be the end
of human inflation but the end result is
that we and our children may be the most
significant generations of humans that
have yet lived the real challenge of our
time is to understand nature in order to
harmonize our behavior with nature not
just to exploit nature technologically
while generating heaps of garbage and
unhappiness how important is it to take
a cosmic view now it turns out that the
entire future of the visible universe
may depend on what we 21st century
humans collectively do at this moment of
transition that's not a month that's not
an overstatement and here's why we
actually know something about the future
of the universe this is based on a
computer simulation by some colleagues
of mine and this first big rectangle
shows our own galaxy and some nearby
galaxies
this whole region expands to an enormous
size such that the little rectangle
surrounding our galaxy becomes this big
rectangle and what you'll notice is that
in 40 billion years when this expansion
has occurred there's hardly anything in
this whole region because of the
exponential expansion of space another
40 billion years now 78 billion years in
the future and that's it that's our
galaxy actually milky andromeda and
nothing visible just about out to the
cosmic horizon when the universe is
twice its present age most distant
galaxies will have disappeared over the
cosmic horizon when milky andromeda has
become for our distant descendants the
entire visible universe our descendants
could have radiated life and intelligent
throughout it in short our descendants
could be the source of intelligence for
the entire future visible universe
alternatively today's humans could keep
thinking small refused to face reality
and over the next few decades destroy
the necessary conditions for our kind of
life to survive the vast majority of
earth species have become extinct
there's no special dispensation for our
branch of the primates but the fate of
other species is no excuse for giving up
on our date power and ourselves because
the very fact that we can understand
this and discuss the options proves that
we have the huge advantage of
forethought there may be microbial life
on many other worlds but it took an
outrageously improbable series of events
on earth plus multiple cosmic
catastrophes to earlier species like the
dinosaurs before we were able to evolve
earth is our only example of the
evolution of life if these low
probability events were essential than
our level of intelligence and higher
maybe extremely rare of course we're all
interested in discovering alien life out
there but we may actually be the only
intelligence of our kind will there be
consciousness and meaning in the future
universe
or will there just be sound and fury
signifying nothing that could be what's
at stake in this cosmically pivotal
moment several times I have heard people
say quite seriously that earth would be
better off without humans because we're
wrecking the environment they claim that
human extinction might not be such a bad
thing but from the point of view of the
universe as a whole intelligent life may
be the rarest of all occurrences and the
most in need of protection we and in
this way I include all intelligent
self-aware creatures that may exist
anywhere we are the universe's only way
of reflecting on itself together we are
the consciousness of the universe the
entire universe is meaningless without
us I'm not saying the universe doesn't
exist without intelligent beings
something would exist but it wouldn't be
a universe because the universe is an
idea and there would be no ideas Earth's
problem is not the presence of
intelligence it's that perhaps we're not
intelligent enough yet to take a cosmic
perspective our challenge is to break
through and see the truest universe of
our time not just as physics but as our
shared mental homeland a homeland where
cosmological time is a normal
perspective and global threats that may
not spin out of control for another
generation are nevertheless as real as a
hurricane that will hit your home
tonight our challenge is to develop a
cosmological vision that can be widely
understood and shared irrespective of
religion and is grounded in scientific
understanding of both the universe and
human behavior since our reality is an
interaction of the two a coherent shared
cosmology like this was for earlier
cultures a source of bonding power that
enabled people to cooperate in ever
larger groups and this is what made
civilization possible a global
civilization will need to cooperate in
much larger numbers the rapidly growing
countries like China and India must be
included
in this cooperation our scientific
understanding of our human predicament
maybe the most important thing that we
all have in common will we rise to these
challenges one thing is certain if we
create this vision if we commit
ourselves to implement it within the
known laws of nature and if in doing so
we create a de facto community that
supports and loves the vision we will
dramatically raised the probability that
the answer will be yes if we wake up to
the reality of our universe and our
predicament on earth if we humbly accept
facts without letting ideologies
suppress or distort them if we become
willing to expand our interpretations of
our religious traditions to encompass
new knowledge if we integrate it into
our thinking and eventually our dreaming
and our art then our culture will have a
new enlightenment and we will become a
cosmic society so think cosmically act
globally eat locally thank you very much